we do need to see in a moderation
of wage rises now that's painful
okay we've got to talk about inflation
food prices are going up energy prices are going
up house prices are going up the rent is going up
everything's going up except for your wages and
andrew bailey the governor of the bank of england
who earns half a million pounds a year
by the way is telling you not to ask
for a pay rise you need to understand
what is happening here with inflation
okay the first thing you need to understand is
that the mainstream media has no idea what is
causing this inflation they're talking about it
as if it's some sort of natural disaster that's
just dropped on the country a cost of living
crisis listen this inflation crisis was easily
predictable right at the beginning of colvin and
in fact i predicted it in my very first video on
this channel look covert was the biggest economic
disaster for a hundred years since the great
depression and how did we deal with it well the
government just simply printed £45 billion
okay that's £10000  for every single adult
in the country okay and if you're not sitting on
ten thousand pounds more in your bank account now
than you were before colby or someone else has got
your £10000 and the facts are they probably
do because all the statistics show us that the
vast amount of that money was accumulated by the
very richest people in the country that means the
richest people in the country stacking up 60 70 80
£100,000 more than they had before covered
okay look if that's how you deal with
the disaster then you can't be surprised
when prices go up these guys are sitting
on 70 80 100 000 pounds more cash okay
that means when your kids go to buy a house
they're competing against these kids who have
a hundred two hundred thousand pounds more
cash in the bank of course prices are going
to go up these guys have a huge amount of cash and
they're going to use it to push up the prices of
food energy houses that you your families and your
kids need okay and that is not going to get better
unless we do something about the huge amount of
cash stacking up in rich people's bank accounts
is the government going to do anything about
it well when you consider that the chancellor's
father-in-law is a billionaire and he himself
is worth an estimated 200 million dollars
i suspect he's probably pretty happy about
the fact that millionaires and billionaires
in this country made a bigger increase on their
wealth during the first year of colvin than they
ever have gotten in any other year in the
history of this country has he raised taxes
on those people well actually he's raised taxes by
two and a half percent on you and your wages and
he's done it in such a way that it specifically
excludes the incomes of billionaires i don't
think he's going to fix his crisis of inequality
and for that reason things are going to get worse
okay so what are the economists who as always have
no idea what they're doing going to do instead of
taxing their rich well it looks like they're
going to and in fact they've already started
raising interest rates what does that mean that
means people who have debts are going to pay more
money to people who have savings okay well who
has debts well if you've got a mortgage it's you
and if you are the government who borrowed
a massive amount during kovitz it's you as
well which means the taxpayer the homeowners and
the taxpayers are going to pay more money to the
cash holders and who are the cash holders here
as we've said it's the rich and the very rich
these guys are gonna try and fix the
crisis by making you and your family
pay more money to the rich do you
think that's gonna work i don't
okay so what happens next the amount of
money in society has permanently increased
that means prices need to permanently increase but
money is no longer pouring in so eventually prices
will stabilize that means inflation will come
back down does that mean the problem is fixed
no inflation will come back to normal but prices
will stay permanently higher permanently higher
cost of food permanently higher cost of
energy permanently higher cost of rent
permanently higher cost of housing the only price
which is not going to become permanently higher
is your wage that's what happens when the
rich get richer but ordinary people don't
your quality of life decreases permanently that's
you and your family the rich will be permanently
richer ordinary people be permanently poorer
and quality of life we permanently decrease
we have to do something about this
okay so what do we do number one educate
yourselves and understand what's happening
don't let them call this a cost of living crisis
like it's some sort of natural disaster understand
that this is being caused by our government
using the kovitz crisis to allow millionaires
and billionaires to accumulate literally
hundreds of billions of pounds at your expense
understand that we can't fix it unless we get
that money back watch the first video on this
channel which explains clearly how that happened
number two is push back don't let andrew bailey
tell you that you don't deserve a pay rise push
for higher wages for you and your work colleagues
don't let billionaire rishi sunac raise your
taxes on you and your family and not raise
taxes on billionaires push for higher taxes on
millionaires and billionaires and lower taxes on
ordinary working people and number three is spread
this message share this video with your friends
your family or work colleagues look there's a
fight going on here and the super rich are winning
the only way we are gonna fight this
is if we come together to push back
okay well i'm here to do my grocery
shopping if i can afford it keep watching
so it's intentionally designed national
insurance so that very rich people
pay a very low percent there is one other thing
they can do with that mass amount of income
they can buy your mom's house